hallo willkommen in meiner wohnung heute
gibt es die lang ersehnte küchen room to
ich zeig euch jeden schrank ich zeige
mich jeden millimeter ihr habt so
ungefähr zwei jahre darauf gewartet aber
wir kamen halt die dazu und hat sich
auch ständig etwas verändert und ein
sage ich euch jetzt schon mal diese
küche ist keine normale küche das tier
gleich merken aber ich stehe gerade am
eingang haben sie das hinter der kamera
und ich würde sagen wir laufen jetzt
einmal durch den flur hier ist übrigens
ein ankleidezimmer das kann ich euch
irgendwann aber das ist auch noch nicht
fertig das war das alte büro ich kann
man ein bisschen schon mal wie sich
zeigt nicht sagen nein das muss ich noch
fertig machen hier befindet sich das
wohnzimmer zeige ich euch jetzt aber
auch noch nicht das kommt dann beim
nächsten mal und viele wundern sich wenn
die app instagram sehen haben auf einmal
ein wohnzimmer sind wir umgezogen nein
dahinter befand sich vorher einfachen
oder befanden sich so zwei
räumlichkeiten die als büro genutzt
wurden von jemand anderes und hier war
eine wand und das wird dann aufgebrochen
und so konnten wir die wohnung erweitern
und ich sag's direkt vorneweg es ist
eine mietwohnung und trotzdem haben wir
viel kosten und mühen auf uns genommen
und das alles hier noch mal verbessert
und nochmal verschönert und jetzt finden
wir eigentlich schon da wo wir sein
wollten in meiner küche macht euch erst
mal einen eindruck es hat sich viel
verändert und ich fange jetzt einfach
mal direkt an mir zu meiner rechten ist
erstmal ein kühlschrank der kühlschrank
ist es ein einbau kühlschrank und wir
haben mit der zeit gemerkt es wird enger
ich glaube so der knackpunkt kam als ich
dann das kochbuch geschrieben habe
anfang des jahres habe ich damit
angefangen das heißt wir haben dann noch
ein zweiter kühlschrank holt ihn zeige
ich euch aber gleich dass wir machen
eine ganze runde könnte auch mal ein
blick reinwerfen ist nämlich
verschiedene
da ist echt nicht viel drin ich nutze
ich nutze die seite eher so als privat
sag ich mal wenn ich mal koch oder so
schnell dahin greife macht ja auch sinn
weil die wege kürzer sind aber zu meinem
anderen büchern kommen wir gleich wie
gesagt dann haben wir hier oben einfach
nur noch so platz für sachen die ich
dann immer mal wieder auffüllen wird zum
beispiel zucker mehl habe ich hier so
sachen die sich nicht lohnen in
vorratsdosen zu tun weil ich mir noch
mal ausprobiert habe wie schmecken diese
nudeln hier zum beispiel auch was was
ich auffüllen muss aber ich will kommen
auch gleich noch mal zu den vorratsdosen
dann habe ich hier ganz unspektakulär
mikrowelle und backofen unter dem
backofen da habe ich die bucks sachen
die ich am allermeisten benutzer spring
formen tortenring und hier in der ecke
sieht man noch backen die nehme ich
immer so auseinander also die kann man
ja ineinander stecken und die sind halt
mega platzsparend das ist jetzt ein paar
kam und das ist der zweite und weil sie
so lang sind habe ich hier meine xxl
winkel palette auch nochmal hier drin
und halt dinge die ich ständig beim
backen brauche wie zum beispiel meine
torten segel mit der echten klinge ich
habe ich noch ein paar teig gehabt und
das war 4 gehe ich halt ständig run
deswegen ist auch dieser platz
reserviert für diese ganzen sachen 1
weiter unten habe ich dann auch nur noch
so
reinigungs zeug hier einmal drin in
solchen behältern hier nochmal zwei war
und taschentücher also nichts wildes
bevor ich jetzt hier weitermachen möchte
ich mein sinngemäß einmal rüber zu
anderen seite also hier stehen wir
direkt ganz oben an der schublade mit
eiern ich habe ganz viele und hier ist
kein mhd ich weiß aber ich bin noch so
ein mensch ich immer dran ich bin erst
gucken meinen sinnen ob etwas noch
haltbar ist oder nicht und
genau und die verbrauchen wer ohne ende
dann habe ich hier noch so sachen wie
kurkuma kapseln die nehme ich jeden tag
mal nämlich kapseln mal nämlich extrakt
und haben sie auch und hier sind noch so
sachen zum frühstücken also aufstriche
und so hier natürlich meine haselnuss
creme die schokocreme die wird noch ganz
oft in der küche vorkommen denn das ist
ja nicht nur zum frühstücken hier sind
schützen und ein paar tücher ich habe
immer von jeder farbe eine schürze
bereit falls ich dann drehen möchte und
hier noch so elektro zeugs zum aufladen
denn hier vorne ist quasi wenn ich am
laptop arbeitet und nebenbei was auf
schreiber an rezepten dann mache ich
hier meinen laptop dran und dann kann
ich direkt von hier aus arbeiten und
dann gibt es noch ein ganz cooles gadget
in dem ich mein handy einfach hier
ableger von hier sieht man dass mein
akku gerade lebt da sieht man es nochmal
das ist auch ganz gut dann kann ich hier
kabellos einfach mein handy auf die
arbeitsfläche stellen und mal aufladen
wenn er zwischendurch mal kein akku habt
so das war die oberste schublade ein
weiter drunter habe ich sachen die ich
dann auch zum kochen brauche aber auch
andere konserven also eigentlich
konserven allgemein und so sachen wie
zum beispiel hier mayonnaise oder malta
hänni dann habe ich hier auch noch mehr
konserven euch merken ich muss auf jeden
fall einkaufen gehen weil sonst ist das
immer noch voller und ich hab so alles
an auswahl da ganz unten ist dann noch
mal so eine art frühstücks schublade da
habe ich hier zum beispiel dass ein
hartes liebling kellogg dann habe ich
ihr
mal haben wir hier noch so ein bisschen
was zum ausprobieren da trifft natürlich
niemals fehlen sonst habe ich auch immer
mehr brot aber wie schon gesagt ich muss
auf jeden fall einkaufen gehen fragt die
habe ich jetzt auch hier gelagert das
sind meine pistazien die haben mir auch
ihren platz gefunden hier immer es passt
natürlich zum frühstück ganz gut mein
rührei gewürz allgemein noch so ein paar
salze und ganz hinten kakao und noch t
wobei das wir trinken kaffee aber wenn
du zu spielen nicht nur nerven lassen
dann ist auch immer cacau wir jetzt
stehe ich hier direkt am herd hier seht
ihr mich ja auch immer in den videos das
ist so mein gebiet hier und direkt und
am herd ich gehe mal ganz runter ist
natürlich ich glaube die bei auch jedem
zuhause man will ja mal kurze wege haben
sind natürlich pfannen und töpfe und da
habe ich selbstverständlich nur meine
eigenen ich habe jahrelang welche sind
gut welche welcher marke kann ich
vertrauen bis ich gemerkt dass ich
niemanden so wirklich vertrauen machst
du deine eigenen und dazu gibt es auch
bald ein video das praktische ist man
kann hier auch immer den griff abnehmen
die sind dadurch auch backofenfest und
den griff habe ich hier ganz einfach die
ganzen kniffe habe ich hier ganz einfach
gelagert und da ist auch die unordnung
drin denn da habe ich meine ganzen
deckel und hier sind dann pfannen und
töpfe also mega praktisch direkt unter
dem herd sind noch so gut in sie liehen
die man auch fürs kochen und fürs backen
braucht hier geht es los mit den ganzen
tag schon da habe ich ja ganz viele von
die brauche ich ihn mir auch gefügt am
tag fünfmal und hier auch superpraktisch
man hebe paletten ja über alles ganz
normale utensilien zum kochen und auch
zum backen und hier auch schneebesen ich
habe ich eine auswahl an tollen dass ich
auch meine eigenen die haben wir auch
noch mal vom material her verbessert
lager ich hier habe ich material also
ich sag mal so zubehör material alles
hier in solchen gelagert wird
übersichtlicher finde winkel paletten
streich paletten wellen schneider
ja man braucht immer wird ein
schmutziger sogar in der spülmaschine
nämlich wie direkt auf nächste so was
ich jetzt höre hier ist nur technik drin
aber dafür zwei steckdosen diesen super
praktisch weil mit den steckdosen kann
ich hier an der arbeitsfläche direkt mit
der küchenmaschine arbeiten das ist
super wichtig weil wenn der haben sich
film für die videos dann kann ich ja
nicht da hinten irgendwo so junger leute
jo ich finde daran machen muss dann wird
alles hier vorne passieren und deshalb
war es auch so wichtig dass hier auch
schön freie fläche ist für die videos
und das passt ganz gut denn ich habe
direkt hier wo ich immer arbeite direkt
hier herunter mein haupt mein haupt
besteckkasten gleich mal hier sind
natürlich alles mist gabel löffel
zwischendurch goldene die werde ich
glaube ich noch aussortieren adecco dann
habe ich hier das meinen non-plus-ultra
torten messer und heber das schneiden
von beiden seiten und hebt es direkt
weil das so eine extrem flache klinger
hat und hier habe ich messer noch mit
drin salatbesteck hier auch nochmal die
winkel palette die bundes sich halt so
öftesten das ist die meistgenutzte
winkel palette deswegen habe ich die
auch hier oben hingelegt und nicht da
hinten glas strohhalme für mein letztes
liebe ich hier im ausstand zu treten ist
auch besser für die zähne backform löser
hat alles so sachen die ich ständig
benutzer direkt darunter ist ein teil
meiner gewürze sind traum wieder vor ja
das ist auch wirklich nur ein teil ich
habe hier zum beispiel also einmal
gewürze diese omas benutze die schon
direkt abgefüllt habe aber auch so
sachen wie macadamia erdnüsse so
angebrochen ist wo ich einfach dachte
nicht packt das direkt um damit
ordentlich aussieht nicht direkt sehen
kann okay wenn ich für ein rezept
macadamia braucht dann habe ich nur noch
so wenig da brauche ich auf jeden fall
noch eine packung macht mich jetzt hier
unten noch so habe das ist jetzt nur
noch das was ich an meinem gewürzen
quasi doppelt habt das heißt wenn ich
zeige euch gleich wo die anderen stehen
wenn da was lässt dann greife ich mir
das einfach von hier und kann das weder
auf zu meinen gewürzen ich mache das so
wenn ich hier am herd stehen schwenker
nach hinten und dann kann ich mir so die
gewürze das sind so die rein gewürze und
links habe ich auch ein treppchen die
gewürze mixen und da weiß ich mal ganz
genau dass wenn wir schon so fan hätte
ich was ganz genau wo was ist klar dass
und liegt schon wieder zurück und das
fand ich eben besser als wenn ich jetzt
im regal verstaue weil so habe ich auf
einen blick also es geht ja eigentlich
die ganze zeit nur darum wege zu
verkürzen das ist nichts anderes symbol
auf der arbeit früher habe ich das ja
auch so gelernt verkürzt deine wege
damit du einfach effizienter arbeiten
kannst und bei den gewürzen ist auch so
wenn ich mit gewürzen arbeite stehe ich
natürlich immer am herd deswegen lager
ich die geburt sei nicht irgendwo
dahinten und bei den gewürzen wollte ich
euch noch sagen lagert sie nicht direkt
unter eurem herd weil die wärme kann
natürlich die gewürze zerstören das
möchten ist übrigens auch noch einen
tipp gewesen von maine kikis kitchen
hacks da kommt bald folge 2 haben sie
folge eins ist ein jahr her was mit uns
los war links euch hier unten da könnt
ihr auch sehen wie die küche vorher aus
dass auch ganz interessant wie immer
direkt zur untersten schublade hier habe
ich so lebensmittel wie nudeln quinoa
paniermehl hat alles was man so fürs
kochen benötigt so können sie haben
viele kohlenhydrate kreis und et cetera
sandplatz ich bin ein großer fan von
vorratsdosen es passt nicht immer es
muss nicht immer seien manche sachen
brauchen keine vorab sagen wenn man die
zum beispiel direkt sowieso immer direkt
benutzt oder das einfach nicht lagern
muss aber so sachen wie paniermehl
nudeln reis ich hatte früher immer diese
packungen daran habe ich ja so ein clip
dran gemacht und das war so unordentlich
aus und beim vorratsdosen könnt ihr
erstes direkt reingucken habe ich noch
genug da und dann geht man auch nicht so
einkaufen nach dem motto ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich noch was da hat und am ende
hat man ihnen wie 5-packung linsen da
braucht kein mensch und so habe ich halt
diese langen vorratsdosen man sich zb
welche wieder los dass auch frau holle
er habe nicht viel haben sie über den
franzosen ist es so diesem so hoch wie
meine schublade also ich nutze den platz
komplett aus hier vorne habe ich noch so
sachen wie rote linsen reis beide weisen
so sachen die benutze ich jetzt nicht
sehr oft aber was sich wirklich sehr oft
benutze sind die sachen die ihr hier
hinter sich und das ist für mich gold
wert weil ich habe mit diesem schubladen
nie arbeit die sind einfach immer
ordentlich man muss nur ganz selten mal
mit einem feuchten lappen drüber vision
und fertig ab und so vielleicht mein
aussaugen aber wirklich nur ganz die
nächsten drei schubladen ich zeige die
haben alle mit backen zu tun denn es ist
einfach unglaublich viel und natürlich
stehe ich auch immer hier wenn ich backe
und nicht nur für die videos auch wenn
ich jetzt privat backe dann nehme ich
mir tatsächlich meine küchenmaschine und
stelle sie hierhin mit der steckdose die
hier vorne ist weil ich einfach mag
alles so wenn man so in den offenen raum
schaut beim backen und ich nicht so auf
die wand starren
ich zeige euch mal was hier ganz oben
ist natürlich die sachen die ich am
meisten verbraucher es geht los mit
sahne fest und backpulver hefe et cetera
all diese ganzen trockenen sachen dann
natürlich vanille extrakt manche
flaschen dass da schon was raus wie man
sehen kann aber in den videos wie ich
halt immer volle flaschen benutzen und
deswegen ist gehört halt dazu hier vorne
habe ich noch meinen dass er sehr
optimistisch auch ganz gern zum backen
hier ist noch pflanzliche blatt gelatine
oder es gibt auch alle rinder gelatine
mittlerweile ja das sind alles sachen
zum warten hier habe ich aber auch noch
löffelbiskuits trainer die benutze ich
auch nur zum backen die snack ich ja
nicht so weit so schmeckt nur halb so
lang weil ich ihr noch ein paar streusel
der einfach umgedreht damit ich sehen
kann welche das sind dann gehen wir
direkt weiter runter da habe ich dann so
sachen wie zum beispiel kondensmilch
hier natürlich auch wieder meine creme
weil die benutze ich ja auch zum backen
wir sind auch schon die veganen creme so
wird unser design aussehen das hat daran
setzen mit 100 papier gemacht aber die
veganen krebs die kommen auch bald freue
mich schon riesig drauf dann habe ich
hier auch vegane schlagsahne aber auch
normale schlagsahne man hat halt nicht
immer frische sahne dann gehe ich lieber
auf nummer sicher falls ich doch mal ein
videodreh kuvertüre angebrochene
schokolade haferflocken leinsamen etc
cocos chips ist nämlich eher alles zum
button und hier geht es dann auch weiter
hier fehlt mir gerade eine zutat ich
weiß gar nicht welche das ist auf jeden
fall habe ich ja auch alles alles
backzutaten von mehl die speisestärke
bis minister puderzucker hier habe ich
auch noch so rios ein plätzchen das sind
für mich alles backzutaten hier ist der
weltbeste krokant ich weiß nich findet
ihr mann sitzt nicht optisch schon dass
er ganz anders aussieht als den den man
so im supermarkt kauft also viel verrate
ich euch dass die gleichen nüsse die in
meiner haselnuss creme drin sind
heute alle hier vorne habe ich ein paar
öle und essig stehen also hier zum
beispiel
es ist schon fast so ein bisschen
newslettern mein apfelessig
schwarzkümmelöl das habe ich immer da
meine olivenöle genau also halt so
sachen die man alltäglich benutzt sachen
die ich nicht jeden tag benutzt die sind
woanders das zeige ich euch gleich okay
die muss ich vielleicht mal gießen aber
ich habe mich auch noch ein paar kräuter
dann geht es hier oben einig weiter zu
regal muss ich glaube ich gar nicht so
viel sagen da gucke ich halt ich habe
zwar so led leisten dran gemacht da
gucke ich halt das einfach im video
ansehen nicht aus sie und ich lag am
eine tortenplatte ganz gerne weil im
schrank ist nicht so viel platz dafür
jetzt stehe ich hier schon einmal im
spülbecken das ist eins von villeroy &
boch das gefällt mir ganz gut weil es
mag es ist nicht so empfindlich man kann
heiße sachen darauf abstellen apropos
heiß hier habe ich meinen wasserhahn das
ist einer wo man halt auch heißes wasser
drauf heraus schießen kann
also es geht wirklich auf knopfdruck
ansonsten auch gefüllt hat das war vor
dabei bräuchten wir ja kinder
wasserkisten kaufen wir machen es
trotzdem aber ich finde es doch nur mein
anderer geschmack aber allein das heiße
kochende wasser ist gold wert ich habe
gar keine gar kein wasserkocher
derjeniger für arbeitsfläche steht und
es geht alles nur ruckzuck selbst
nudelwasser hole ich mir das einfach
daraus und aus pudel was also ist
sowieso schon superschnell durch
induktion aber da eben noch schneller
und gerade heutzutage ist kann einem
doch nicht schnell genug gehen oder
direkt unten drunter ist
vor allem schokolade
dann habe ich direkt darunter wie auch
bei jedem wahrscheinlich
hier habe ich einmal rest und riss mit
und plastik ich habe noch einen zweiten
restmüll den zeige ich euch gleich hier
sind spülmaschinen tabs und ein paar
müllbeutel spülmittel und das war es
auch schon direkt daneben ist die
spülmaschine ist es nicht viel zu
erzählen außer dass ich sie am tag etwa
400 mal benutzt und dann machen wir hier
oben am besten direkt weiter hier habe
ich meine schäfchen für die videos ich
muss ja mal wiegen und in neutrale
schälchen legen und da habe ich das hier
alles von einem ort aufbewahrt direkt
daneben sind noch so ein paar gläser zu
trinken und viel mehr gibt es dazu nicht
zu sagen diese eintreffen ganz praktisch
weil dann habe ich das nochmal so
unterteilt ich finde dann auch noch mal
ein bisschen übersichtlicher und dann
gehen wir mal weiter runter das sind so
die alltag teller weich mal nudeln oder
für suppen für essen muss so dass wir
jeden tag benutzen drachen sein dass
letztlich alle teller das melodie die
wir wirklich ständig im alltag benutzen
und die anderen zeige ich euch gleich
auch noch und direkt darunter sind dann
nochmal so ersatz christian für meine
küchenmaschine oder hier auch nochmal so
große schüsseln 7 dann habe ich hier ach
guck mal spoilern vision weder haben
sagt wobei die gans nicht geschafft die
haben es nicht geschafft trotzdem habe
ich jetzt aufbewahrt das gefühl mir
optisch jetzt es doch optisch ganz cool
aber es war nicht so pflegeleicht
deshalb haben wir auch gelassen aber
leute diese bento box event o box hat in
die engere auswahl geschafft und wir
waren damit schon picknicken es macht so
viel spaß sein wird einfache sachen
vorzubereiten
so von dem zeug also hiervon habe ich
gar nicht so viel muss ich sagen ich
benutze immer meine vorratsdosen und die
gehören deiner mama und ich habe ich
habe drei stück davon ich muss ihr die
alle wieder neben sorry schwiegermama
wenn du das gras hinzu wir sind schon
fast wieder hier am ofen angekommen sie
haben es schon eine ganze runde gemacht
guck mal rein was ich hier verbirgt das
ist eigentlich eher so die station wenn
man mal was verpassen möchte ich hier
frischhaltefolie alufolie dann habe ich
aber auch meine spritzbeutel die haben
mich einen platz gefunden solche clips
die braucht man halt immer mal ofen
handschuhe und eine waage also die
brauche ich ja auch jeden tag ich bin
halt einfach übersichtlich habe das hier
alles abgetrennt dann habe ich hier
nochmal beschriftung geräten schere et
cetera also als so ein bisschen
organisatorische direkt darunter habe
ich die ganze schublade reserviert für
meine ganzen für meine ganze fläche und
schon bist du vom rc also meine ganze
fläche das gelochte das imaginierte ich
benutze eigentliches backofen blech gar
nicht mehr ich benutze grundsätzlich
schon lange nicht mehr seit jahren nicht
mehr die fläche die man im backofen mit
dazu bekommen beide haben immer nur
wölbung und die verziehen sich auch beim
button deswegen hat man voll oft einfach
ungerade böden oder die böden sind
irgendwie in der mitte nicht durch
gebacken aber dafür außen ich habe hier
immer entweder das gelochte dann kann
man auch noch von unten luft bekommen
und das zirkuliert halt besser oder
einfach das emittierte gerade backblech
allerdings euch mal in die infobox für
mich ist es ein richtiger lifesaver weil
dadurch einfach die sachen viel besser
gelingen und ich bekomme auch manchmal
die nachfrage oder auch mal hinbekommen
wie e mails wenn ihr euch zum beispiel
einen bug rahmen also meinen back rahmen
kauft und ihr liegt es dann auf euer
blech was ist vom backofen automatisch
mit dabei hat also das mit der werbung
man fragt ihr euch warum läuft mein teig
aus und das ist eben der grund weil er
diese werbung in der mitte ist und eben
nicht das blech komplett gerade ist man
im meile backbleche ist auch noch so
dass ich das beim backen auch nicht
verzieht durch die hitze also es gibt
eigentlich nur vorteile und das ist dann
halt einmal investitionen da hat man das
immer und das ist auch noch vorstellbar
werbung ende aussieht einmal wagen für
der allerletzten schublade von dem
bereich der küche haben wir
schneidebretter oder allgemeinen bretter
sperrige sachen und hier ein paar
aufsätze für die küchenmaschine und
allgemein noch so ein handrührgerät und
die ganzen dienten zubehörteile und die
habe ich noch so 23 auflauf förmchen
also hier ist auch nichts spektakuläres
drin aber ich bin sagen wir praktisch
hier so körber noch zunehmen weil wenn
es jetzt so darin liegen würde dass wir
so eine unordnung und damit vermeidet
ihr eben diese unordnung nochmal das war
jetzt der erste teil der küche da hinten
gesund zweiten teil da können sie gleich
darauf zurück dass video bietet also ein
bisschen länger kurz zu den eckdaten die
küche hat eine matte oberfläche es ist
mit beckermann küche und die
arbeitsplatte das waren wir so am
allerwichtigsten die arbeitsplatte die
ist von leo lietz kann man jetzt nicht
vergleichen mit einem keramik es ist
noch mal so eine ganz neue technik auf
der oberfläche kann man heinz der
schöpfer ablegen und man kann darauf
schneiden das sind so zwei sachen die
mir super wichtig waren denn wenn ich
mal mit zitrone halbiere dann will ich
mir nicht gedanken machen müssen dass
ich ein schneidebrett untendrunter habe
oder wenn ich mal ein top schnell zur
seite legen wo es über kocht oder bevor
irgendwas anderes möchte ich mir keine
gedanken machen und das gibt mir so
viele freiheiten daher bin ich super
happy mit der neo liter fläche und was
ich auch noch sagen möchte dass es auch
wichtig gewesen für mich gerade weil ich
videos die ich wollte keine standard
dunstabzugshaube die oben an der wand
integriert wird sondern ich wollte gern
einen mulden lüfter haben das ist eine
integrierte abzugshaube die ist quasi
hier drin die zieht auch die größe die
zieht die dämpfe die zieht einfach alles
ein muss kann man hier einfach so raus
nimmt kinderrechte steckt das auch jedes
mal in die spülmaschine und dann ist es
wieder wie neu und da darf auch ruhig
mal wasser rein kommen da dürfen ruhig
mal zum beispiel essensreste
überschwappen das passiert halt mal beim
kochen unter 54 gar kein problem und man
kann halt jedes noch mal vorstellen das
heißt wenn ich jetzt hier auf der seite
koche dann schiebe ich das natürlich
diesen regler nach links damit es schön
alles eins sieht wenn ich beide felder
benutze dann das ist einfach so in der
mitte und zieht von beiden seiten dann
alles ein das kochfeld ist von der firma
bärbel und ich bin ich habs jetzt über
zwei ringe brauche ich bin mehr als
zufrieden und ihr fragt mich auch voraus
unter meinen videos was ist wenn du was
free tigers oder riecht es nicht hier
ist alles offen ich muss sagen nein
bisher habe ich noch gar keine probleme
damit gehabt kochfeld von bärbel gefällt
mir sehr gut und weiter geht's hier zur
theke das war so früher unser
essensbereich und wenn wir mal besucht
hat man wenn man ihnen die zwei leute da
waren wir haben uns hier so gequetscht
aber ich liebe diese theke nur ist es
halt nichts für die dauer und es ist
nichts für wenn man besuch hatte ich
habe jetzt ja auch nur noch zwei stühle
stehen die anderen weg genommen denn wir
haben wir jetzt unseren esstisch die
theke dies auch aus will teilte die
gefällt mir super gut und die gesamte
küche habe ich geplant mit küchen
malachi ihr kennt küchen mal nach
erkennt familien auch wenn nämlich auf
instagram verfolgt dieses video ist
keine kooperation keine bezahlte werbung
durch darüber denn wir haben noch weiter
weiteren stauraum ist echt ein traum
muss ich sagen dass man so viel stauraum
hat und die frage hier direkt los hier
habe ich noch so teetassen oder auch
kaffeetassen die ich gelegentlich
benutzer aber jetzt nicht jeden tag und
untersetzer habe ich da noch vorne habe
ich noch so ein pub sachen wenn ich mal
doch was mit gebe dann will ich keine
teller mit geben muss an menschen die
ich vielleicht doch nicht so oft sehe
wir backen ja echt viel hier habe ich
unter anderem davon habe ich teller wenn
zum beispiel besuch kommt dann nehme ich
gern die weißen unheimlich ist natürlich
nicht so oft benutzt die nämlich auch
nur werden besucht da ist und hier oben
ist alles kunterbunt das sind nämlich
teller die ich dann für food fotos
benutzt habe ich echt viel aussortiert
deswegen ist ja auch nicht mehr viel ja
und so sachen die ich wirklich selten
benutzt aber ich will ja nicht ständig
um die küche rumlaufen und was zu nehmen
deswegen stehen wir auch genau hier so
haben wir eigentlich müssten wir jetzt
kamera tauschen eigentlich müsstest du
jetzt deine seite vorstellen soll ich
machen für dich wirklich oder oder du
rede findet meine haben soll was das ist
einfach wahr langweiliges technik zeug
das muss keine listen langweiliges
technik zeug um batterien und
fernbedienungen und hier noch ein paar
kabel ich glaube das könnte sie das muss
ich auch zurückgehen falls ihr euch
fragt wo die ganzen fünf boxen sind die
stehen einmal hier hinter dieser
trennwand das ist mal haben sie das
aufgabe das aufzuräumen
aber es ist okay
so ist doch in ordnung wenn ihr trennen
und dafür sieht man eh nichts mehr aber
wie geht es dir über denn die küche hat
noch uns zweiten teil das soll noch
nicht alles wir haben hier einen café
corner dadurch dass halt jetzt hier kein
wohnzimmer als zwei folge eine wohnküche
habe ich gedacht ich möchte gern popcorn
aber es ist ein coffee corner ich habe
das wort eigentlich nur ausgedacht das
ist einfach so eine station unter
anderem man sie erfand kaffee können ich
bin ja so ein kaffee liebhaber und da
haben sie auch und hier steht auch schon
unsere maschine und ich für euch jetzt
einfach mal so ich hab ja von und die
maschine stehen natürlich mit meinem
café glück meinen kaffee und ich ist
nicken wir halt auch immer so ein paar
datteln hier habe ich einfach noch so
also kaffee ist es nicht aber immer in
verbindung mit ihrer süßen deswegen
stehen hier ganz viel ganz viele süße
sachen und dann fange ich einfach mal
hier links an das sind diesmal
schränke mit so ein drucksystem das
heißt ich mache einmal auf dann habe ich
hier eigentlich die die wir tagtäglich
benutzen die ganzen gläser und hier auch
unsere
doppelwandigen gläser hier unten dann
auch noch mal sowas oder hier das buch
schon immer zum kaffee machen das habe
ich hier immer parat und dann gehe ich
eigentlich direkt mal so die ganzen
schränke and lernen direkt darunter habe
ich dann auch noch weil teetrinken
dieses so selten eigentlich sogar er nur
für besuche deshalb habe ich eigentlich
so provisorische abgestellt vielleicht
könnte es auch noch über stellen genau
die habe ich jetzt hier noch drin hier
da habe ich das alles noch unterteilt in
so großen körben natürlich ganz viel
kaffee damit wir auch immer auf vorrat
haben
wenn der kaffee aus ist dann wenn es
richtig schnell schlechte laune hier
habe ich auch noch so also unter anderem
aus guitar aber auch so große sachen wo
ich mal was drin ablege ich eine
tortenplatte noch unter anderem halt
alles so rundes zeug und ein paar
süßigkeiten
ich muss sagen die es sich nicht die
würde ich dann auch für eine torte
benutzen aber unter anderem wenn ich
meinen kaffee macht nec ich dann hier
immer mal wieder was oder ist man
wechselnde sortimente leute ändert sie
steht ich habe sehr gerne süßes ist so
in der mitte das auch wieder das gleiche
also hier habe ich also muffin zeugs
also
muffin förmchen ausstecher da bleibt
dann muss ich nicht oft dran deswegen
liegt das auch hier hier so ein paar
weckgläser da brauche ich auch nicht of
trust deshalb liegt es auch hier weiter
geht es hier mit süßigkeiten unternahm
baklava und loccum diesen übrigens bald
wieder versuchen das ist tatsächlich die
allerletzte packung sie auch noch
verschweißte trauen sich die zu öffnen
aber nachschub ist er unterwegs und
diese müsse kleiner fun fact diese nüsse
die sind ummantelt diesen so lecker die
hatten darauf unser hochzeiten die gäste
waren so
lecker hier kann ich tatsächlich nicht
so viel in den körben zeigen was man
alles tempels und
hier genau ist umso zubehör für die
kaffeemaschine so hier haben wir
eigentlich auch wieder samples hier oben
dh das ist hier unsere toilette so sei
die flasche wird auch nicht in der farbe
auch nicht in der farbe wir haben uns
eine andere farbe entschieden aber das
ist schon mal das design hansa hat das
habe ich selber auszudrücken das ist so
ausgedrückt hier unten habe ich auch
noch so sachen die ich hinten als in der
küche nicht stehen habt zum beispiel man
rosen wassermann orangenblüten wasser
klammer tabuisierung ich habe überall
natürlich mein schwarzkümmelöl weil auch
wenn man leute kommen ich drück das
jedem in die hand weil das ist einfach
ich verstehe nicht warum man das nicht
nimmt hören wir es mal so da hinten ist
noch rapsöl et cetera also alles so
sachen die ich mir dann nähme wenn ich
sie brauche euch braucht sie hat mich
oft
ich glaube dafür lohnt sich den einbruch
bei uns
ich glaube darum beneiden und gehört
ganz viele aber wir hoffen wir dass wir
auch die creme bei dem supermarkt finden
oder haben sie dann ja
oder ihr bestellt fährt einfach online
aber das ist so eine creme vorrat ja die
geht natürlich ganz schnell bei uns weg
und habe ich hier natürlich auch noch
baklava die hinten habe ich noch so
hagebutten pulver et cetera alles an
pulver noch nicht so brauche diese
kleinen liegt die kommen also diese
kleine haselnuss krimi leser die gibt es
auch manchmal gratis bei bestellungen im
shop ja da haben viele gefragt ob man
nicht auch kaufen kann
für die dekoration queen of qatar dazu
gibt es bald ein rezept weinstein pulver
ist in deutschland noch nicht so krass
vertreten und ich schade finde die amis
vorgemacht das ist ein super back trieb
mittel und ich habe jetzt endlich
jemanden gefunden der mir das quasi
besorgt in einer topqualität und hier
oben sind auch die gläser die dann beide
habt ja gefragt wann gibt es die endlich
in groß so werden nieder
und natürlich wird das etikett noch ganz
andere also hier meist ganz schnell hier
sind sachen die ich natürlich selten
braucht weil ich es besteht grad auf
einem hocker und ich komme so nicht ran
deswegen das sagen nicht nicht so oft
brauche ganz links kann ich euch nicht
zeigen da ist ein templates für ganz
großes projekt so was habe ich da ganz
oben noch
da oben fertig mir für mein kochbuch
gekauft
aber dürften auch so ganz große sperrige
sachen jemand einmal im jahr braucht
jetzt stehe ich hier direkt am
kühlschrank und über kühlschrank und
immer zwei körper in einen öffentlich
sind eigentlich zwiebeln kartoffeln drin
aber wir sehen sehen wir hier ein hauch
von nichts denn ich musste und einkaufen
gehen also ich hab es ist also ich weiß
nicht was los ist und auch heute ist ein
feiertag auf der anderen seite ist
machen corp
und da habe ich nochmal so
frischhaltefolie
schalteten gefriert tüten alufolie
täterin und ja die zahlen aber so groß
und sperrig habe ich einfach auch mal
hier rein gepasst so werden ein video
zur entstehung des kochbuchs gesehen hat
hat gemerkt wie verzweifelt ich war das
war ein auf und ab der gefühle und und
ob kam auch noch das problem dass ich
nie platz hat dem kleinen kühlschrank
deswegen haben wir uns dann kurzerhand
ein dazugeholt ich finde steht ja auch
ganz gut und das ist ein amerikanischer
der geht so schön auf und ich gebe es zu
ich hab natürlich aufgeräumt bevor ich
diese proben zugedreht aber da habe ich
hier gehört
es ist ja echt mega leer es sind die
vioso backzutaten aber auch ist das
verdrehen also ja wir haben nichts
gedreht ist was ich hier noch zitronen
und aloe vera ich wollte meine maske mit
aloe vera machen computer tik tok vorher
war das so da war kein platz und dann
musste ich jemand was stelle ich die
frage lautet raiffeisenbank auf
zimmertemperatur stehen können und jetzt
kann ich so glücklich drei kurven rein
stellen ohne probleme und heute das ist
goldwert immer viel eher machen müssen
hansa und darunter ist noch gefrierfach
da es auch negativ platz acht hier
kommen uns recht können auch die zweite
serie a ha
alexa näumann
und das war auch noch so ein kleiner
traum nehmen uns erfüllt haben weil wir
wollten einfach noch so was richtig
cooles in der küche dieser küche wieder
ich am anfang gesagt hat dass eine
kleine küche und ich habe jetzt versteht
ja auch warum wir haben quasi einmal die
küche wir haben den coffee corner wir
haben hier unsere neon wann bitteschön
begrünung und ich finde es bringt
nochmal richtig wärme rein es ist ja
keine arbeit denn das ist alles
antistatisch das heißt da da wird gar
kein staub hingezogen und mache einfach
gar keine arbeit damit und das liebe ich
ja kommt die studie dass die klimaanlage
die wird uns diesen sommer leicht helfen
letzten sommer sind sie ein gegangen vor
hitze und dies jetzt auch neu und da
kommen wir an im sommer auch schön
weiter drehen haben sagen ustream folgen
ja sogar zwar freundlich das war's das
war es leute ich hoffe es nicht gefallen
ich hab echt viel gequatscht aber es ist
doch eigentlich gibt es so viel zu sagen
warum ich wo was hingestellt habe darauf
bin ich jetzt gar nicht so wirklich
eingegangen aber dafür gibt es auch kiki
sketchen hacks tägliches kitchen jack's
teil eins habe ich euch gezeigt wie
jetzt die sachen haltbarer machen können
etc kikis kitchen hacks teil 2 dass wir
den ordnungs editioun da kann ich euch
auch noch mal tipps und tricks geben ich
hoffe dass euch die kultur gefallen er
habe als nächstes gehen wir dann rüber
zum wohnungsmarkt auch noch viel zu
erzählen sondern ein arbeitszimmer ich
zeige euch auch gerne mal das alte
arbeitszimmer das jetzt ein
ankleidezimmer geworden ist aber ihr
müsst ihr dazu einfach in die kommentare
schreiben was euch interessiert damit
ich auch weiß ob das gut ankommt oder
nicht ansonsten verlinke ich euch alle
wichtigen sachen hier unten in die video
beschreibung wenn wir zum beispiel
vorratsdosen et cetera oder bestimmte
produkte falls ihr daran interesse habt
und wünsche euch jetzt einfach nur noch
einen wunderschönen tag fühlt euch alle
umarmt bis zum nächsten mal